warum schreibt ein alter mann von 75
jahren ist man nicht mehr ganz jung
bücher stiller mit dem thema klima wir
haben in europa in den letzten jahren
wirklich erfolge beim abbau von co2
emissionen ein erfolg aber ich bin
trotzdem wirklich wirklich sehr sehr
besorgt weil das klimaproblem ist ein
globales problem ist ein planet unseres
planeten ein problem unseres planeten
und die co2 emission überhaupt die
ganzen treibhausgasemissionen dazu wird
methan stickoxide usw sind immer noch
weltweiten am steigen wir haben keinen
rückgang die haben immer mehr aber wir
haben nicht nur steigende steigende
treibhausgases werte die haben auch
immer noch jedes jahr 75 millionen
menschen mehr lebt in einer welt wo im
letzten jahr 2000 milliarden nicht nur
ich wir alle
2000 milliarden dollar nicht millionen
milliarden dollar für militär und
rüstung ausgegeben werden obwohl
eigentlich 98 prozent der
wissenschaftler sagen das ist dass dies
die klimaentwicklung die erderwärmung so
dramatisch ist das ist und dass die
zukunft unserer kinder enkelkinder und
überhaupt der ganzen natur wirklich
schlecht bestellt ist deshalb habe ich
einen revolutionären gedanken dass die
menschheit endlich lernt mit vertrauen
politik zu machen und ich mit misstrauen
dass wir weltweit einen zu einer
abrüstung komme und dass wir dieses geld
diese riesigen summen und auch die
energie die da ist einsetzen um wirklich
alles zu tun in diesen zehn jahren
zwischen 20 und 30 deutlich die
emissionen zu reduzieren dass wir wieder
hoffnung haben und die menschheit
geworfen hat das ist mein anliegen
deshalb schreibe ich bücher heraus mit
ihren direkten frage ist immer auch die
menschen angesprochen die immer mehr
werden was würden sie denn dagegen tun
also würden sie darüber gesprochen
arbeiten hat national oder wie würden
sie es mal frau schenk ist noch einfach
ganz simpel die allermeisten länder auf
der erde müssen nichts tun weil da gibt
es geburten raten von 2 und unter 2 aber
wir haben in afrika ein riesenproblem da
gibt es in den meisten staaten immer
noch geburtenraten von fünf kinder pro
frau oder niger sogar sieben kinder
alleine in indien steigt jedes jahr die
bevölkerung um 12 millionen das macht
also in sieben jahren einmal deutschland
84 millionen also an in einigen
brennpunkten auf der erde würde ich und
da bin ich total radikal ein kind
politik machen aber deshalb weil hat gab
es ja schon mal ja arbeiten in china
weisen doch richtig in china was doch
richter nicht doch allein nein platz
noch
zu
dass er auch aus peking sehen smog ja
wenn in china nicht vor 25 jahren ein
kind politik gemacht hätte dann hätten
wir heute nicht in china 1,4 milliarden
menschen werden heute 1,7 milliarden
menschen und je mehr menschen auf die
auf diesem planeten kommen desto mehr
artensterben haben haben wir desto mehr
tropische regenwälder werden gehört
abgeholzt aber heraus matinee menschen
haben es geht oder rossmann wirklich man
kann so viel fahren und deiner
manuela better nicht zu sagen wir machen
eine bevölkerungs management und wir
verwegen menschen kinder zu bekommen
dann ist da ich doch erraten
menschenrechten wie es schlimmer nicht
sagt ist oder nicht und herren ich will
die ein-kind-politik entziehen ich hab's
doch mal meine frau in china erwischen
wie jungs sie haben eine generation
geschaffen ich rede doch nicht 90 95
prozent der länder da gibt es nicht mehr
aber es kann doch nicht sein dass in
afrika in den nächsten 20 25 jahren nach
informationen nach auskunft der
vereinten nationen eine milliarde
menschen dazukommen wir haben doch in
deutschland lebt da karmann derzeit
millionen dazu da haben wir hier mit
einer afd bekommt und sonst was wir
können doch diese entwicklung nicht ein
paar ist immer die afg es jetzt nicht
was wir können doch diese entwicklung
sich so gut schreiben lassen der planet
kann die menschen nicht mehr ernähren
wir werden heuschreckenschwärme haben in
wenigen jahren unvorstellbar lesen sie
mein buch lesen sie die gesamte
hintergründe ich will keine ein kind
politik wäre funktioniert auch die liga
genau gesagt sind nehme ich so rossmann
bevölkerungswachstum mach hand in hand
mit wirtschaftswachstum falsch was sie
sagen nein nein nein jeder hat das
zurückgenommen weil sie mittlerweile
weil die frauen ich hier nur noch ein
kind bekommen aber das war eine
entwicklung über 25 jahre nein was da
passiert ist in der zeit mit der
ein-kind-politik ich muss da auch aufs
schärfste den riesenplaneten können
werden jedes jahr weitere 75 millionen
menschen auf dieser erde war das nur ein
gerät das genau so realistisch wie wir
die finanzen sehen müssen müssen wir
auch dieses problem werde es aber bei
der ein kind politik zum beispiel ich ja
nicht fordere ja nur in ganz wenigen
regionen aber in afrika von euch sie ein
dadurch sollte sie in ägypten in kairo
leben mit 20 millionen menschen in einer
szenischen das sind menschen verschenkt
die haben keine medizinische versorgung
die haben keine bildung die haben keine
chance im beruf zu finden wissen sie was
die jungen menschen in afrika sagen und
was diesen größere hoffnung ist
irgendwie nach europa zu kommen das sind
doch keine
lebenswerten oder das sind doch nicht
umstände in denen sie oder ich leben
wollen also die hälfte aller länder
weltweit haben haben bedeutung
geburtsrate unter 1 0,7 das problem ist
nicht und 12 unter 20
1 ist falsch unter 2,7 das stimmt einen
geharnischten und wie dem auch sei ihr
hammer und stellt eine geburtenrate von
1,4 ist alles nur zwei heißt ich glaube
schon dreißig vierzig jahren habe ich
doch keiner alleine lesen ich rede über
indien und ich rede über den kontinent
afrika der in ein elend hineinwächst und
ich finde dass inhuman ich finde das
unchristliche menschen in eine welt
hinein hinein in die welt zu bringen
also haben auf menschen würdevoll
gegeben ich folge dir sein bin ich
engagiert ich vermisse dich
fertig freute diese debatte sozusagen
mit großer spannung und aufmerksamkeit
will aber beitragen am liebsten wäre es
mir dann würde es den menschen selber
überlassen es gibt aber und da und da
ist einfach so sind habe was man was man
vielleicht ist sozusagen noch mehr in
der hand hat als geburtenzahlen in
anderen ländern oder gar kontinenten ist
ja was machen wir hier und ich fand den
abrüstungs gedanken
spannend weil er natürlich auf der
hoffnung beruht dass krieg ausstirbt
dadurch auch und das sozusagen die der
gedanke sich selber verteidigen zu
müssen aus der mode kommt denn man
braucht eigentlich die größte
verteidigung die man machen kann wenn
ich diesen vergleich richtig verstehe
ist dem planeten zu retten und deshalb
braucht man diese vielen vielen
milliarden dollar für ganz was anderes
was was was das würde mich wirklich
etwas was verlangen sie sozusagen von
uns was wir beitragen können jeder von
uns damit der planet sozusagen eine
bessere zukunft hat jede entwicklung
weltweit auch die soziale entwicklung im
neunzehnten jahrhundert hatte erstmal im
hintergrund dass etwas gedacht wurde
also erst mal gab es ein karl marx so da
gab es die die sozialdemokratie es gab
herr strunz in frankreich noch im jahre
1870 kinder 8 19 jährige buben die schon
zehn stunden am tag in bergwerken
gearbeitet haben die sozialdemokratie
die entwicklung von freyberg schafften
war notwendig also erstmal muss was
gedacht werden und das was ich in meinen
büchern und schreibe was ich denke da
geht es um vertrauen und da geht es um
diese heute würde man sagen der rossmann
ist ja gar der der spinnt ja aber die
wissenschaft ist sich ziemlich sicher
dass wir keine weiteren zehn jahre mehr
so weitermachen können wie bisher und
reden bringt uns nicht weiter wir müssen
zum handeln kommen und deshalb würde ich
wenn ich eine bundesregierung anführen
würde der wäre ich die größte nervensäge
ich würde den leuten zu bringen und
tutin und auch den amerikanern auf die
füße treten
28 prozent der weltweiten emissionen
emittiert china 14 prozent die usa knapp
fünf prozent russland das heißt diese
drei wichtigsten militärisch wichtigsten
und vor allen dingen wirtschaftlich
wichtigsten nationen der erde
verursachen fast die hälfte aller
emissionen wenn wir hier in deutschland
denken dass wir mit unseren lächerlich
kleinen 1,9 prozent beitrag die welt
retten können dann ist das absurd dass
auch wieder wir haben eben über
ehrlichkeit der hebel geht über
animieren oder geht er mir über
animieren die animieren oder mehr über
druck ja ich bin ein völliger fantast
weil das was ich denke was ich denke und
sage herrscht trotz habe ich im dezember
geträumt übrigens genauso wie frank
schätzing also der hat der schätzing hat
sein buch der schwarm vorher getroffen
ich habe mein buch geträumt und stand
dann ab januar 20 richtig unter druck
aus diesem traum ein buch zu machen er
stand in albtraum wäre das ist kein
alter
da muss ich hab' ich sage ja nur
partiell in vielleicht fünf prozent der
länder auf der erde müssen wir darüber
nachdenken
[Musik]